♪ ♪
>> Emily: ANOTHER TWIST IN THE
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS SCANDAL.
LORI LOUGHLIN'S DAUGHTER OLIVIA
DATA'S ARE IS REPORTEDLY FURIOUS
WITH HER PARENTS AND THINK THEY
RUIN HER CAREER.
SHE'S BEEN DROPPED BY MAJOR
BRANDS INCLUDING THERESA
MAY.
ACCORDING TO SOURCES, HER
PARENTS FORCED HER TO.
SHE ADMITS THESE DEVELOPMENTS,
THERE'S A NEW TERM FOR THIS TYPE
OF PARENTS, THEY ARE BEING
DUBBED SNOWPLOW PARENTS BECAUSE
THEY TRIED TO CLEAR OBSTACLES
OUT OF THE WAY OF THEIR KIDS,
EVEN AS ADULTS.
>> Dana: I HAVE A THEORY THAT
THIS IS PLANNED.
THEY HAD A FAMILY MEETING AND
SAID OKAY YOU SHOULD GO OUT AND
SAY THAT YOU'RE REALLY MAD THAT
YOU NEVER REALLY WANTED TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND WHEN THE DUST BLOWS
OVER, WHEN IT ALL GETS RESOLVED,
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A REALITY
SHOW AND IT'S GOING TO BE
SOMETHING WHERE THEY GET A LOT
OF MONEY TO TALK ABOUT THEIR
DYSFUNCTIONAL FAMILY AND HOW
RICH THEY ARE AND HOW THEY
DIDN'T REALLY WANT TO GO TO
COLLEGE.
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE A
SHOW.
>> Emily: WHAT'S INTERESTING
IS GIVEN THE TROUBLE THE PARENTS
ARE IN, THERE WILL BE SUCH A
DISGORGEMENT OF FUNDS AND
FINANCES AND WAGE GARNISHMENT
FROM THE FEDS IF THIS CONTINUES
DOWN THAT LINE AND WHATEVER
MONEY THEY MAKE FROM THAT.
>> Greg: WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
IT IS DISGORGEMENT A WORD?
I'VE NEVER HEARD THAT WORD.
>> Emily: YES.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Greg: I LEARNED A WORD.
>> Emily: WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF
YOUR GIRLS CAME HOME AND SAID
DAD, WE JUST WANT TO BE
SOCIAL MEDIA INFLUENCERS.
>> Jesse: I WOULD CHANGE THE
WORLD RIGHT THERE AND THEN.
THAT'S WHAT THIS YOUNGER GIRL IS
RUNNING UP AGAINST.
IF YOU TRY TO EMANCIPATE
YOURSELF OR TRY TO BADMOUTH YOUR
MOM AND DAD IN THE PRESS, THAT
WILL GETS CHANGED IN A
HEARTBEAT.
I WOULD BE VERY CAREFUL BECAUSE
SHE'S GOING TO BE IN THE
POORHOUSE IF SHE DISRESPECTS HER
PARENTS LIKE THAT.
MY PARENTS WERE THE OPPOSITE OF
SNOWPLOW PARENTS.
I TALKED ABOUT AT THE OTHER DAY
HOW THEY MADE ME DO THESE
OUTDOOR WILDERNESS ADVENTURE
SURVIVAL SCHOOLS.
I HAD TO SLEEP IN LIGHTNING
STORMS.
WE CARRIED A KID OUT ON A
STRETCHER MADE FROM TREE
BRANCHES BECAUSE HE SHATTERED
HIS KNEE.
I WENT THROUGH SO MUCH HELL AND
HEARTBREAK.
THEY PUT ME OUT THERE.
THEY GAVE ME THREE MATCHES AND
SET I WILL SEE YOU IN THREE DAYS
AND I SURVIVED BY MYSELF.
I HAD SEVERE SUNBURN.
WE HAD ICE PICKS THAT WE WOULD
CLIMB UP THE MOUNTAIN WITH.
WE HAD A 10-MILE FUN RUN AT THE
END OF THE TRIP.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
>> Emily: I THINK YOU ARE
SAYING THAT BOY SCOUTS WAS HELL.
>> Jesse: IT WAS BOY SCOUTS ON
STEROIDS.
IT WAS A LOT MORE THAN THAT.
>> Emily: GREG, I'M SURE YOU
FEEL STRONGLY.
>> Greg: I'M NOT SURE IF THE
STORY IS TRUE BECAUSE IT BEGINS
WITH "SOURCES SAY."
BUT IF TRUE, THE TWO GREATEST
WORDS IN JOURNALISM HISTORY, THE
DAUGHTER IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SHE FIGURED OUT THAT SHE DIDN'T
NEED COLLEGE AND SHE LOOKED
AROUND AND SHE SAW THAT SHE
COULD PURSUE A CAREER IN
SOCIAL MEDIA.
THIS WAS MY KID, I WOULD'VE BEEN
SO GRATEFUL THAT I DIDN'T HAVE
TO PAY $100,000 A YEAR AND THAT
THIS KID IS ALREADY MAKING A
LIVING OFF OTHER DUMB KIDS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
I THINK SHE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THAT SHE HAVE THE RIGHT WAY AND
HER PARENTS WERE FORCING AN OLD
IDEA ON HER BUT SHE KNEW BETTER.
SHE KNEW MAYBE I DON'T NEED
COLLEGE.
MAYBE I'M NOT SMART ENOUGH TO GO
TO COLLEGE.
MAYBE I COULD JUST FLEECE PEOPLE
ON INSTAGRAM AND BECOME SUPER
RICH.
I AM THINKING I WANT TO HAVE A
KID LIKE THAT.
>> Jesse: YOU WANT YOUR KID TO
FLEECE PEOPLE.
>> Greg: YES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: YOUR KIDS ARE SO
ACCOMPLISHED.
>> Greg: THE REPUBLICANS, YOU
MEAN?
>> Emily: DO YOU AGREE WITH
WHAT GREG IS SAYING OR DO YOU
FEEL LIKE A DEGREE IS VALUABLE
NO MATTER WHAT?
>> Juan: I LOVE EDUCATION.
I THINK IT TEACHES CRITICAL
THINKING, TEACHES YOU HOW TO
DEBATE.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT SPEECH IN
THE PREVIOUS SEGMENT.
I THINK YOU SHOULD HEAR PEOPLE
OF DIFFERENT OPINIONS AND
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES.
I THINK THAT'S THE WORLD WE LIVE
IN AND IT'S GOOD FOR YOU.
BUT I WILL SEE IN THIS CASE, I
THINK THESE ARE CANDY CANE KIDS.
THEY ARE MELTING IN THE RAIN.
I THINK THEY ARE SPOILED RICH
KIDS TO NO END AND THEIR
PARENTS, THE PARENTS HAVE THEIR
OWN REASON FOR WANTING THEM TO
GET INTO COLLEGE WHICH I THINK
HIS STATUS.
BUT EVEN IF -- LET'S SAY YOU
SAID YOU KNOW, KID, I WANT YOU
TO GO TO COLLEGE BECAUSE I
BELIEVE IN COLLEGE, WHY WEREN'T
THEY SATISFIED WITH LETTING
THEIR KID GO TO COLLEGE THAT
THEY COULD HAVE MERIT EARNED
ADMISSION TWO.
THAT WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH FOR THEM
BECAUSE OF THE SOCIAL STATUS OR
WHATEVER.
TO ME IT'S A CORRUPTION OF
VALUES AND MORALS AND I DON'T
APPROVE OF IT.
I THINK THE KID IS VACUOUS AND
SELF-SERVING.
>> Greg: SHE KNOWS THAT.
THAT'S WHAT'S GREAT.
SHE KNOWS THAT SHE'S VACUOUS.
>> Juan: WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO